okay so in Attack on Titan the one
moment that changed everything was when
Levi gave Armin the Colossal Titan if
the captain had chosen to save Irvin
instead then the whole timeline
obviously would have been way different
and today we're about to explore how the
rumbling would have ended in this
alternate reality by the way in case
you're new to the channel you should
probably know that this video is the
final part of a seven part Series so if
you want to catch up on everything so
far then all you need to do is click the
link on screen for everyone else I'd
appreciate if you smash that sub button
if you've enjoyed the story so far and
don't forget to stick around till the
end if you want to see which characters
actually survive
all right so the best place to start
this video off is with Mikasa who's
slowly be waking up as the sun begins to
set in this moment the last thing she'd
remember is flock trying to blow her up
in Liberia but strangely she wouldn't
have a single memory of anything that
happened afterwards as she then
gradually opens her eyes she noticed
Aaron quietly standing ahead of her and
based on their surroundings it'd be
clear that somehow they've made it back
to shiganshana this realization would
cause a million questions to start going
through mikas's head but before she has
time to even form a complete sentence
Aaron would begin to say something
looking towards the sunset he'd tell her
that he's glad she's finally conscious
since he's been standing in this exact
spot for weeks waiting for her to
recover the reason they came to this
specific location is because it's the
same Hill where they always used to play
as kids and he thought that being here
might subconsciously help her to wake up
however with no recollection of even
traveling to parties in the first place
she'd responded by just asking him how
exactly they arrive back home
immediately that question would cause
him to go silent and he'd keep facing
off into the distance almost like he's
afraid to look at her his unusual
behavior would definitely give mikasara
a slightly uneasy feeling by this point
and actually repeats the question she'd
also ask whether Levi and Historia are
okay this would be followed by an even
longer awkward silence but after a while
Aaron would reluctantly have to turn
around the depressing look on his face
would instantly let her know that
something's wrong but to explain why
he's upset we first need to understand
the truth about what happened in Liberia
as we already know flock believed that
the ackermans were the only ones who
could kill Aaron and so to stop them
from interfering with the rumbling he
detonated the Armored Titan the blast
was so powerful that any regular human
would have been vaporized but for Levi
mikusa and Astoria they were still alive
as they fell towards the ground during
that long 70 meter drop Irvin tried his
best to catch their unconscious bodies
but the slowness of his Titan meant that
he was too far away to reach them in
time meanwhile Aaron's Vision was
partially crowded by all the smoke
coming from the rumbling meaning he
didn't properly see the acumens until
they nearly Hit the Floor by then it was
way too late to intervene and so in a
moment of desperation he brought Mikasa
to the Past Dimension which as you
probably guessed is where they are right
now in part he spent weeks waiting for
her to recover and as her body was being
rebuilt Aaron tried to think of
different ways to save her in the real
world for example one of his ideas was
to transform her into a pure Titan to
increase her chances of survival but he
had to give up on that plan and several
other plans due to ackermans being
unaffected by the founding Titan in the
end after considering basically every
possibility Aaron realized that he was
once again powerless to save the person
he loves when he was 10 years old the
same thing happened when he couldn't
save his mother from being eaten and
then it happened again when everyone was
brought back to life instead of Armin on
both occasions Aaron could only watch as
his family were taken away from him but
what's especially tragic now is that he
still can't prevented even with his
Godlike abilities after explaining all
of this to Mikasa she'd understandably
be horrified and super confused in her
mind the idea that her real body is
seconds away from Death while her
Consciousness has been in the past
dimension for weeks is something that'd
be hard for any human to process arima
tries to calm the situation by
reassuring her that none of this was her
fault and he'd tell her that he never
would have activated the rambling if
he'd known that this would be part of
the future just like in the main
timeline he wouldn't have seen
everything and so this whole situation
would genuinely be catching him by
surprise he'd gone to confess that ever
since Armor's death he's been paranoid
about losing her and that every choice
he's made including the rumbling itself
it was to guarantee that she'd be able
to live a long life remember Aaron is
known for years that the curse of Emir
was going to kill him one day and so his
goal was to die knowing that Mikasa and
the people he cares about would be safe
No Matter What getting emotional she'd
reply by letting him know that she
understands because from the day he gave
her that scarf she's kind of basically
felt the same way we've seen before that
migas's biggest fear is Aaron dying and
it's why she always put everything on
the line to save him regardless of how
dangerous it happens to be it could be
argued that this overprotectiveness is
the main way she expresses her love for
him considering that she's never been
explicitly romantic but in their last
moment together Aaron would finally take
the hint as he gives her a kiss this
goodbye smooch is something he'd
probably been wanting to do for about
five years and he'd hoped that by doing
it now it'll allow Mikasa to pass away
without any regrets during the middle of
the kiss the surrounding environment
would then suddenly collapse reverting
into the typical blue pass Dimension
that we're used to seeing seconds later
Mikasa would then Disappear Completely
into the void but what might surprise
you is that even with Mikasa being gone
Aaron wouldn't be alone in this
Dimension off in the distance there'd be
someone behind him seemingly tied to a
cross and on close respection the person
would turn out to be none other than
flock for weeks the armor Titan has been
trapped here in this position with no
way to move his body no one to talk to
and no idea how he arrived in Parts
although I think he would have tried to
stay strong in the beginning by now the
isolation would have mentally broken him
down to the point where he'd just be
desperate to escape by any means
necessary that's why when Aaron
unexpectedly appears in front of him
he'd call out to him for help as if the
two of them are somehow still friends
having just seen mixer vanish because of
what flogg did Aaron would angly turn
around grab him by the neck and start
screaming at him about why he blew
himself up the armor ties him and tried
to defend himself by arguing that he
didn't have a choice because the scouts
were prepared to kill Aaron to stop the
rumbling in particular he'd highlight
the details of Evan's conversation with
Willie Tiber and he points out that the
acumens are immune from the founding
Titan's power this immunity combined
with their insane combat skills meant
that only Levi or Mikasa would be
capable of killing the founder that
being said Aaron would fight back by
telling flogg that Mikasa would never
try to kill him but even if she did he
still want her to have a long and happy
life after all having already seen Armin
be sacrificed for the greater good of
the island Aaron would openly question
why everyone he loves has to to die in
order for eldia to be free flock would
simply respond by reminding him that not
everyone he cares about is gone in fact
Connie is back home on the island and
doing better than ever after being
reunited with Mrs Springer this reunion
was only possible because Aaron kept
relentlessly fighting over the years and
so the Armored Titan would urge him to
finish what he started so that Connie
and Sasha can have the peaceful lives
that Aaron wanted them to have
interestingly in spite of everything
flock is done I think his words would
resonate with Aaron because it would
remind him that there are still people
back home that he needs to protect if he
was going to stop the rumbling now then
it would put all those same people in
danger because the Global Alliance will
retaliate whether it's in 10 years time
or even 50 years time for that reason
following an extremely long pause Aaron
would accept that for the sake of his
remaining friends he does need to finish
what he started but just because he
agrees with flock would it mean that he
forgives him grabbing him by the shot
one more time Aaron would describe in
detail how he's going to make flocks
suffer and die in the worst way
imaginable and with that they be
transported back into the real world in
this reality only a handful of seconds
would have passed since the Armored
Titan exploded meaning the scouts would
still be falling through the smoke with
no one able to save them their bodies
would crash into the ground at full
speed instantly killing both ackermans
and creating a powerful shock wave that
could be felt across Liberia as a side
note given that Historia is a Titan
shifter I highly doubt she'd die from
the impact as well but it didn't make
sense for her to at least be knocked
unconscious now when it comes to
Commander Ervin it's the fact that in 99
of situations the death of two Scouts
wouldn't really affect him throughout
the series there are countless examples
of him either disregarding or gambling
with people's lives and it's why flock
referred to him as the Devil Himself the
commander has also been described as
someone able to abandon his own Humanity
but following Fox betrayal it'd be hard
for Evan to suppress his true emotions
after everything he and Levi have been
through he just never would have
expected Humanity's strongest Soldier to
die in the hands of another Scout what
makes it worse is that a year earlier
they were the ones who trusted flock to
be the one to eat Rhino so for him to
now stab them in the back with that same
power that they allowed him to have it'd
be super unexpected in a situation like
this it wouldn't take long for his
feelings of sadness and confusion to
turn into blinding rage as he reaches
out to crush the Armored Titan although
flock would be insanely outmatched he
still at least raised his fist to defend
himself and just as Urban is about to
deal the finishing blow he suddenly feel
a hand in his shoulder the hand in
question would belong to Aaron who'd
politely tell the commander not to worry
about flock since he already has his own
idea for what he wants to do with him
surprised Evan would quickly realize
that whatever's Happening Here must be
one of the founding Titans tricks
because as he glances around he noticed
that they're Frozen in Time literally
nothing except himself and Aaron would
be able to move inside this Dimension
and as the commander looks down he'd see
an old memory of Captain Levi I probably
don't need to explain that this specific
memory is from five years ago when Levi
had to decide who would inherit the
Colossal Titan I at the time Mika sir
and Aaron quite literally fought for
Armin to be the one chosen whereas
everyone else seemed to think that
everyone was the most logical choice
however in the present day Aaron would
now believe that regardless of who was
saved neither Armin or Irving would have
been able to stop the rambling the real
truth is that as long as subjects of
Emir can become Titans at any time then
the rest of humanity will fear them for
being monsters that fear is one of the
main reasons why it's so difficult for
eldians and humans to coexist but until
recently Aaron had deluded himself into
thinking that Irvin might find a way
sadly even the best leader in the best
plan wasn't able to find a peaceful
solution and so ld's only remaining
option is to either destroy Humanity or
wait for Humanity to destroy them in
response the commander would hesitantly
admit that Aaron might be right although
there's a reason why he still wouldn't
be happy about the rumbling from his
perspective even if this worldwide
Massacre succeeds it's hard to justify
sacrificing billions of people for the
freedom of their one tiny Island after
thinking for a while he'd remind Aaron
that when Carl fris originally trapped
aliens Behind the Walls it wasn't only
their freedom that he took away the
reality is that subjects of Emir across
the sea also lost their freedom as well
and if it wasn't for their sacrifices
Aaron never would have made it this far
for example people like Grisha Dinah and
Kruger were all from Liberia and it was
thanks to their actions the eldians on
the island had the tools to survive
continuing this train of thought the
commander would suggest that Cedric
suvimir born outside the walls are no
different from them and so if Aaron
truly wants aliens to be free then that
freedom should be extended to aldians
worldwide of course Aaron would reply by
asking how that would even be possible
to which Evan would give him a practical
solution as the rumbling continues to
March the founder can transform all
these people into pure Titus who can
then join him on his Rampage across the
globe once it's all over they can then
start brand new lives on parodies but at
first Aaron would be majorly skeptical
about this plan given that many aldians
across the sea will hate him for destroy
the planet I think Evan would also have
to acknowledge that possibility but
while it's true that some people won't
be happy there are thousands more who
will be grateful that their families
weren't trampled a proposal like this
would be a lot for Aaron to process but
after thinking back to his dad's
memories he would accept that maybe the
commander has a point it can't be denied
that Elders from across the sea laid the
foundation for everything Aaron has
achieved and so for him to turn around
and kill people just like them it would
make him no better than the malians for
that reason alone he'd agree to play
along with Evan's plan on the condition
that he takes migas's body back home and
gives her a proper burial next to Armin
and as the two of them shake hands in it
the scene would flash back to Liberia on
the streets people would be freaking out
as their skin begins to Glow yellow and
from Gabby and Falco's perspective
they'd probably think they're about to
die across the town thousands of Lights
would then erupt out of nowhere as every
last man woman and child would be
transformed into a Mindless Colossal
Titan standing at 60 meters tall their
explosive Transformations would destroy
what was left of this City and
interestingly this same thing would be
happening all over the world in every
country where internment zones exist the
audience there would unexpectedly turn
Titan and would join the rambling as
they trample everything surrounding them
at the same time while all of this is
going on the attack Titan would briefly
switch his attention to flock in the
past we've seen how the people who've
betrayed Aaron have usually ended up
being killed by someone else but in this
instance he'd want to personally deal
with the armor Titan having already
mentally tortured the guy for weeks I
guess the only thing left to do now
would be to physically tear him apart in
the real world to accomplish this Aaron
would use the founder to forcibly
transform flock back into his human form
before tossing the body into his own
gigantic mouth as Aaron's teeth then rip
his former friend to Pieces flock
screams would be heard for Miles as the
rumbling continues to move forward both
the wall Titans and the internment Zone
Titans would keep marching through the
ruins of Liberia but despite their
incredible speed it would still take
them five more days for the rambling to
be completed with the exception of eldia
every last corner of the Earth would be
flattened until All That Remains would
be a Barren Wasteland filled with the
remnants of humanity billions of people
entire civilizations and entire cultures
would all be wiped out in less than a
week and this disproportionate act of
violence is something that Aaron was
selfishly willing to do to protect the
handful of people he has left by the
time he then arrives near the shores of
the island ever would already be there
waiting for him having made preparations
for the internment's own refugees a few
days earlier in front of a packed
courtroom the commander would explain
how elia's population has significantly
declined during the past decade due to
war famine and Titan related incidents
therefore the arrival of subjects of
Emir from across the sea could be a
great opportunity especially due to
their knowledge of the modern world
their knowledge of modern medicine and
Technology could help fill the Gap left
behind by his route and it would allow
the island to keep advancing for
generations to come despite that many
people would still be unsure about the
large influx of foreigners including
Premier Zachary who wouldn't really know
what to do when way earlier in this
timeline you might remember that in part
3 Zachary announced his retirement with
Evan being selected to replace him at
the end of the year although the year
wouldn't be over we need to remember
that number one this character has
already fulfilled his main goal as
commander-in-chief and number two it'd
be clear from Urban speech that he has a
Clear Vision for how to integrate the
refugees for those reasons I think
Zachary would pretty much have to do the
sensible thing and retire early allowing
Premier Smith to have final say on how
Society moves forward after the rumbling
flashing forward 18 months I think a ton
of things would have changed on the
island by now especially in the capital
city in the underground a giant Monument
to Captain Levi would nearly be
completed with Irvin personally
overseeing the construction for decades
the people of the underground have
almost been completely ignored by the
Royal government which is partly why the
crime there was allowed to get so out of
control Levi himself was a well-known
criminal before he joined the scouts and
if he'd never met Evan then it's likely
he would have wasted his potential for
that reason the commander-in-chief would
want to make sure that people down here
have access to better opportunities
which is why in addition to the Statue
the government would make large
Investments to improve infrastructure
and provide various educational programs
meanwhile in another area of the capital
Willie Tiber would be locked up in a
brand new cell closer to where his
family are living because the tibers
have such extensive and valuable
knowledge of the modern world and also
knowledge of the history of the aliens
they'd receive a degree of special
treatment compared to most refugees it's
how they'd be able to negotiate Willie
and Peak being transferred into these
better conditions in exchange for the
tibers cooperating with the military
that being said at this moment there
still wouldn't be any chance of them
being released from prison which is why
Gabby would genuinely be brainstorming
ideas for how to break peek out of
herself later that same evening Colt
would give a passionate speech on behalf
of aliens from across the sea many of
whom would be suffering from intense
discrimination it's a fact that many
locals on the island would associate the
actions of Mali with the people who were
coming from over there and that
Association would 100 lead to violence
against them this hostility would be
similar to how aldians used to be
treated outside the internment zones in
Mali itself and as Evan and Historia
listen to what Cole has to say they'd
realize that the scale of the division
is even larger than they first expected
now when it comes to how Aaron would
adapt to this new world most of his time
would be spent in a forest towards the
south of the island to explain how he
ended up here the first thing we should
remember is that he is still a human and
the guild from killing billions of
people and the guilt from getting Mikasa
dragged into it it would weigh heavily
on his mind as time went on it's
unavoidable that he'd feel more and more
ashamed about his actions but what would
really mess with his head is that he'd
be treated like a hero everywhere he
goes on the streets of Alia he literally
be worshiped for wiping out their
enemies and there isn't a single place
he'd be able to go without people
glorifying what he did when you combine
that with the severe PTSD he'd be
suffering from eventually Aaron would
get so overwhelmed that he'd isolate
himself from the rest of society for
almost a year no one would have any idea
where he was as he'd be living off the
land and he'd only ever leave the forest
for one reason once or twice a month
he'd make the long journey to
shaganchana in order to visit that tree
on the hill because underneath this tree
is where both Armin and Mikasa would be
buried every time he see them he'd come
to just apologize and ask for their
forgiveness but by pure chance on one of
his visits his story would show up a few
minutes after him despite the Garrison
searching for Aaron for 11 months this
random meeting would be the first time
anyone one has seen him since his mental
breakdown more than anything his story
would just be relieved that he's alive
and she'd explained how worried she's
been ever since he disappeared Aaron
would respond by telling her that she
shouldn't waste her energy on a person
like him especially after what he did to
her family specifically however she just
let him know straight away that a lot
has changed since that day and if he's
truly sorry then he'll come back and
help them confused Aaron would ask what
she's even talking about and this is
when she tell him about the new crisis
on the island even within this tiny
world people would rather hold on to the
trivial things that used to divide them
rather than embracing the fact that
fundamentally they're all the same Aaron
would disregard this by saying that he
never expected for the rumbling to
suddenly make Society perfect and that
the main thing he wanted was for aldines
to be able to live their lives without
fear of being wiped out Historia would
argue back that the refugees are living
in fear of being wiped out every day and
although Aaron's doing what he can the
hatred they're facing is only getting
more and more intense many of Aaron's
followers and Believers are the ones
causing the most trouble and so if you'd
wonder if maybe he could help change
their perspectives if he made a return
to society after a brief pause he'd
explain how he doesn't know if he can
because in his heart he's felt useless
ever since the power of the Titans
disappeared 18 months earlier when the
rumbling was complete the founder yamir
vanished that same day along with all
Ty's abilities whatever she wanted
whether it was revenge on the world or
something else she left once all her
descendants made it to the island it was
partly because of this that Aaron slept
into his old mindset where he believed
that there was nothing special about him
and that without his powers he had
nothing to offer Humanity surprisingly
though out of nowhere Historia was
suddenly give him a hug and she just
tried to reassure him that what he's
saying is completely wrong even though
she majorly discreets with him when it
came to doing the rumbling she said
enough to know that his worth as a human
was more than just him turning into a
Titan regardless of whether he has the
power or not there are still thousands
of people out there who believe in him
and who'd probably preferred if he was
the one in charge that would cause Aaron
to laugh for the first time in over a
year and as he hugs her back he thanked
her for what she's been trying to do his
story would reply by asking if that
means he'll come back with her to which
he just let her know that he's not ready
at this point but that he'd like to
arrange for them to meet at this
particular spot again
with that said that is the end of this
alternate timeline in which Evan got the
Colossal Titan and if you've made it
this far then I want to thank you for
watching the past seven videos I'd
appreciate if you guys let me know what
were your standout moments from the
whole series that you liked the best I
gotta say for me personally my top three
moments were Aaron using the Warhammer
Titan to its full potential
um another thing was Historia summoning
Urban to the Past Dimension I think that
was probably my favorite plot twist in
the whole thing
um and flock betraying Mikasa was also
pretty cool as well anyway thanks again
for sticking around for the 17 months
that has taken me to complete this
timeline and uh yeah be sure to
subscribe if you want more what if
content like this until the next one
peace out